[Música]
bom vocês imaginem um uma atriz avon que
era confeiteira em berlim no início do
século 19 um avô de origem alemã que era
padrão dono de restaurante e por ser
descendente de alemães e por cultivar os
hábitos alemães
ele foi preso durante a segunda guerra e
ele só foi solto porque o pessoal da
cidade onde ele vivia é pediu pela
polícia só o padeiro porque nós
precisamos de pão
uma mãe cercada de comida desde que
nasceu e que frequentou vários cursos de
culinária é onde segundo ela como ela
muito bem fala é é a vela entrava dentro
de uma gaiola viva e saia no prato
pronta para ser consumida
e naquela época as aulas eram
ministradas no apartamento na casa da
professora então imagine a logística
disso enfim todas essas esses pequenos
relatos essas pequenas histórias não
fazem nenhum sentido simplesmente a
gente só conseguiu contatá lá só pra
vocês assim mas a partir do momento que
elas foram cantadas pra mim passadas de
geração em geração elas passa a criar um
valor dentro de mim quando essa parte da
gastronomia da comida ela não mata
simplesmente a minha fome
se eu vou dizer pra vocês um dos
primeiros dos primeiros elementos quando
a gente é criança
a gente acaba é tendo alguns dos
sentidos mais aguçados
eu posso dizer que nessa parte digamos
relativo à comida
o meu é meu estilo é o meu instinto mais
apurado era o fato é é claro que cada um
de vocês e dizer pra vocês assim imagine
agora um bolo saindo do forno
você consegue imaginar até o gosto dele
praticamente
acho que isso é normal pra todos mas pra
mim tem alguma coisa que antecede esse
cheiro do bolo do bolo do bolo saindo do
fome você acredite ou não o cheiro que
vi que me vem à mente é o cheiro do
motor da batedeira da minha mãe
batendo as gemas o açúcar que eu depois
fazer parte da massa enfim esse o fato
de sentir o cheiro do motor da batedeira
para vocês terem uma ideia isso mostra o
quão perto já estava do preparo com
papel do agente estava da cozinha do
balcão não estava fazendo isso ou seja
com perto a gente tava é dessa comida
além disso quando a gente é criança a
gente estava exposta aos mais variados
ingredientes e que a gente fazia na
volta da aula o que acontecia a gente
pegava uma castanha pegava uma noz um
pedaço de morango uma cereja mergulhava
no chocolate e se essa pequena coisa
fazia o mais maravilhoso mais moderno
chicletes perder toda a graça
a gente vinha pra casa à tarde que tinha
tarde às 3 horas o 3 6 1 o horário que
sinceramente ninguém tem fome mas como
boi tradicional família a gente sentava
na mesa para tomar um café
mas nós sentávamos o café nescafé
significava muito mais do que matar a
fome e como eu já disse ninguém tinha
fome naquela hora não era ou comer era o
fato de a gente dar uma pausa nas nossas
tarefas é uma uma pausa no trabalho do
lar enfim os nossos deveres fim ea gente
sentava em volta da mesa para tomar um
café
cada um na sua esse momento esse momento
gerava comunhão
esse momento gerava lembranças
a gente fala lembranças e lembrança é
remete a gente remete a pessoa se remete
a receitas é eu acho que cada um de
vocês aqui tem uma ideia pelo menos ter
uma ideia do que seja um caderno de
receitas não digo livro de receitas que
a gente compra na livraria
mas um caderno de receitas ficaram em
receitas nada mais é do que uma
compilação de receitas que nos
interessaram enfim o que foram gostosos
o que alguém passou que a gente copiou
de algum lugar e por vou marcar no meu
caderno de receitas os nossos
seus amigos nossos colegas de classe a
gente vai pra casa deles enfim a mãe
tinha um caderno de receitas e tal olavo
aquilo ali é nossa mãe nossa mãe não tem
um manual de cima porque isso acaba se
tornando o nosso manual nossa mãe não
tem um manual de se ela tinha um negócio
um pouco diferente
você imagine agora aqui ponto que um
caderno de receitas de se pudesse se
transformar num álbum de lembranças
'nunca de um livro de recordações ou
então num álbum de fotografias
enfim qq que gera recordações era mais
ou menos isso ea gente questionava a
minha mãe porque minha mãe não tinha
nada mais nada menos do que uma pasta de
arquivo um bem simples com plásticos e
folhas em branco mas onde ela colava
receitas escritas à mão e como vocês
podem ver todos os papéis originais
enfim manchado já saiu a papéis com
quantos anos coleta da minha avó conta
das minhas tias coleta da vizinha
exatamente o papel original ela colocava
aqui e têm papéis em alemão tem receita
em alemão enfim tem coisa que mostra
realmente o sinal do tempo enquanto ela
usava ea gente dizia mãe porque não faz
como as nossas amigo como nossos amigos
que pegue tem aquele caderno bonito
coleta igual tudo bonitinho
adicione o que me dá mais prazer é
quando vou fazer uma receita
eu abri essa pasta eu sei exatamente a
cor do papel tamanho do papel a letra
escrita eu sei está em alemão português
você quem me deu a receita e me lembro
também de quantas vezes das vezes que eu
fiz a receita ou então de quem me passou
essa receita ou seja mais uma vez a
gente vê a gastronomia às receitas o
preparo relacionado com gente
relacionado com lembranças e agora vocês
podem imaginar um patrimônio de vocês
podem imaginar o quebra pau que vai dar
um dia para saber quem é que vai ajudar
essa páscoa né enfim só é um acervo que
a dona sueli do patrimônio histórico a
lhe fazer inveja
o nosso dia é super corrido
a gente sabe que não tem mais tempo para
nada
é trabalho em cima de trabalho ea gente
quer render cada vez mais cada vez mais
do que normalmente a gente faz
substituir se a gente não consegue
trabalhar tão fácil a gente o tão rápido
a gente substitui a máquina
o nosso trabalho então são máquinas
trabalhando no nosso lugar então nós
trabalhamos com máquina e um negócio é
vira um mundo totalmente automatizado
também no lance da gastronomia também na
área da gastronomia néel enfim grandes
indústrias e tal e que o que importa é o
dinheiro enfim o tempo é dinheiro e
dinheiro que interessa então não se não
fala mas isso não é essa evolução e o
que a gente pode resumir isso são
máquinas alimentando máquinas simples
assim
em um estágio é que eu fiz recentemente
na alemanha é eu também tive
oportunidade de ver o quanto essa
evolução foi saudável para o mercado e
quanto dos trabalhos originalmente
feitos é pela mão enfim o pelo artesão
pelo padeiro pelo confeiteiro foram
substituídos pelas máquinas
é o trabalho passou a ser praticamente
todo ele é automatizado né isso eles foi
uma revolução saber que cabe aqui dizer
também que eles estão há 30 ou 40 anos à
nossa frente na tecnologia e é onde um
bom empresário enfim que visa uma
lucratividade uma competitividade quer
chegar
qual não foi minha surpresa quando eu
trocar uma idéia com o pessoal onde eu
trabalhava enfim profissionais
professores eles dizem olha mas nós
lamentamos que tenha chegado a esse
ponto
vocês ainda não sei lá 30
tecnológicamente 30 40 anos atrás atrasá
los mas vocês ainda tem esse toque vocês
ainda faz essas coisas com a mão é um
trabalho artesanal então hoje é
extremamente valorizado na alemanha esse
trabalho esse toque do artesão do
padeiro do confeiteiro é no pão na massa
enfim o que quer o que quer que seja
vocês terem uma idéia tão voltando a
usar o forno a lenha e um pão no forno à
lenha na alemanha é um negócio tão
espetacular porque faz 30 40 50 anos que
nem começo
pelo menos não com prado é
industrialmente não comprado
cadu é o mais impressionante é quando
essas mesmas pessoas com quem eu falei
lá vieram aqui pro brasil experimentar
um
a culinária é da nossa região e qual não
foi minha surpresa quando eles disseram
nossa isso é que eles nunca tinham vindo
pra cá
isso aqui sim que vale a pena essa
receita que isso que eu tô comendo
realmente tem o gosto de 40 50 anos
atrás tem o gosto da casa da minha avó
ou então têm o gosto do cheiro da casa
da minha avó ou então têm o gosto do
cheiro da casa da minha mãe eu gosto do
que era preparado naquela época então
não perca essa originalidade não percam
essa fidelidade a receita não perca a
fidelidade aos ingredientes e também a
naturalidade dos ingredientes consumo
eles o mais naturalmente possível o que
se deduz disso um alimento feito por
gente num determinado espaço de tempo
com o tempo para ser consumido
o dirigente também com tempo para poder
curtir esse a gente come alguma coisa
meio atravessada que todos vocês a usar
essa expressão né acho que me de ser
alguma coisa meio atravessada
ou então uma outra expressão que
acredito que 101 por cento das pessoas
que estão aqui também já usaram
e não tô me sentindo bem
foi alguma coisa que eu comigo eu
pergunto pra vocês será que foi uma
coisa que vocês comeram ou será que foi
o modo como vocês a comerão será que a
gente não precisa de um tempo para
consumir a gente não precisa de um
ritual gente não precisa de um pouco de
calma para assentar em algum lugar e
consumir alguma coisa para comer
será que eu não preciso de um tempo
também para poder compartilhar coisas
com os meus colegas com os meus amigos
que seja 10 15 minutinhos
mas há uma parada para poder consumir
isso ou então hoje é terça-feira hoje a
quinta feira é o dia do grande em todo
mundo sabe o que é crendice
licha zinho aquela rodinha de senhoras
com aquele cabelo branquinho branquinho
melhor idade né
aquele cheiro de perfume fortíssimo né
pessoas unidas numa mesa grudadas numa
mesa e degustando aquele momento e quem
sabe se vai terminar um bom jogo de
cartas é porque ninguém é de ferro né
mas enfim ela se reúnem
você tem idéia de quantos sorrisos
acontecem entre uma garfada de torta e
outra de quantos olhares se cruzam entre
um gole de café e outro
isso são momentos e esses momentos são
extremamente especiais e eles dependem
de vocês
ele depende de cada um de nós é claro
exige disciplina mas vou sair do âmbito
agora comercial fim do espaço onde a
gente usa pra comer o espaço público e
vamos pensar na nossa casa
qual é a cultura da alimentação na sua
casa
vamos começar pelo café da manhã
em cinco minutos é quando é um
café-da-manhã cumprido porque
normalmente é menos você pega para a
venda da geladeira abre a porta da
geladeira jovem com o prato já pega a
fatia de pão está dentro do do saco
plástico dentro da geladeira
faça alguma coisa no pão fé tiro leite e
fecha a porta da geladeira
o pé enquanto isso já pega cápsula
pergunta dentro da cafeteira com a outra
mão tu pega caneca coloca debaixo e isso
já tá comendo e depois tira com café
pronto já vai engolindo porque seco nada
desce
então esse esse é o café da manhã o
almoço normalmente não dá porque à tarde
o filho tem inglês a depois tem natação
depois tem o seu quem enfim não se faz
nada à noite cada um que assiste a sua
novela né então não dá para sentar de
novo na mesa
então normalmente salvo exceções mas
normalmente a gente acontece acontece
assim será que a sua família os seus
filhos ou você principalmente
lembra de uma boa mesa lembra de uma
mesa posta lembra de sentar à mesa para
fazer uma refeição não precisa agora
então se uma mesa com toalha e tudo pode
ser aquele banquinho colocado na frente
do sofá com uma bandeja mais uma bandeja
montada pra você qual foi a última vez
que vocês acender uma vela pra comer
não tô falando do restaurante famoso em
que queimou aquele jantar romântico à
luz de vela né
é eu estou dizendo uma vela e também de
um jantar romântico a dois que é meio
óbvio aquela velha eu tô falando quando
você está sozinho mesmo está com sua
família enfim aquela velha em cima sabe
pra que não revela do recheio também não
vale
tá só aquela vela pra aquecer o ambiente
tá tornar o negócio mais especial quando
vou como é que você costuma fazer pra
limpar a boca numa refeição quando
sentar numa mesa o que está fazendo a
cada refeição é básica posso adivinhar
um pedaço de papel toalha ou então pagou
com leite ou alguma coisa assim o papo
com café ou alguma coisa leu uma notícia
no jornal enquanto estava engolindo a
torrada cuspiu e tal vida para trás o
que já está em pé na cozinha não está
sentado na entrevista para trás na pia
abre a torneira lava a boca e passo o
plano da pia
ninguém tá vendo mesmo é só você pra que
eu vou fazer uma cerimônia os jogos de
porcelana os talheres as xícaras os
pratos as dicas de consumo e os pratos
de sopa os bullies eles estão lá
guardados
eles estão guardados para muitos de
vocês aqui também há dez anos esperando
um momento especial
eu vou esperar uma ocasião especial para
usar como diz o bom alemão não esse é o
meu jogo pão
eu só uso quando tem visita só em um
momento especial
há dez anos sem tirar esse jogo do
armário
tudo bem não quer quebrar é um jogo
lindíssimo com debrum em ouro 24 peças
de carro
nada mas é uma decisão muito triste
porque há dez anos
você só tá sem uma ocasião especial
quando estiver comendo alguma coisa tá
lá guardado pra nada
enfim será que a sua família sabe a
diferença entre uma vez aposta em uma
fatia de pão e torrada e um suco é
comido rápido indo para o carro
será que eles sabem o momento que isso
gera
será que ele sabe o que quer uma
comunhão a com crazy mesa será que eles
já experimentaram isso quanto tempo faz
que você no experimento é isso a gente
precisa disso a nossa alma precisa disso
o nosso corpo precisa disso a nossa
mente precisa disso e como falei uma
questão de disciplina uma questão de
persistência persistência acordar uns
bons minutos mais cedo
se você quiser fazer isso no café da
manhã mas vocês não têm noção do impacto
que isso vai ter na vida de vocês
nas lembranças de vocês nas memórias de
vocês
qual é a probabilidade de um momento
como esse
entrar para a história de vocês imagine
então se você se expandir isso expandir
isso e convidar os amigos convidar os
colegas e vocês a passar um momento
juntos
como eu falei a gente tem várias fontes
a gente precisa nesse momento para
refletir a gente precisa nesse momento
pra sentir para perceber para escutar do
que o nosso apetite tem fome
a nossa alma precisa passar por isso ela
precisa ser satisfeita o nosso corpo
precisa ser satisfeito e só dessa forma
você vai poder levantar de uma mesa e
dizer eu estou satisfeito de corpo e
alma eu li uma frase que tem já um tempo
que tem perseguido por exemplo tenho
pensado muito nisso eu queria usar isso
para vocês agora é o meu desejo de
coração é que vocês possam cada vez mais
e cada vez mais com mais prazer com mais
prazer dizer
nossa estou me sentindo tão bem
eu acho que foi uma coisa que eu comigo
[Aplausos]